-Last time you were on the show,
we hugged goodbye there.
I said, "Good to see you again."
And you go, "Dude, I haven't
told anyone this yet, but --"
-You were the first person
I told.
-I was, right?
-Yeah.
-"I'm getting my own show."
I go, "Oh, my God, dude."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you.
-That was -- I mean, it was
a year ago, right?
-A year ago. Yeah, a year ago.
I'm in the club now.
-Now, we're in the club.
We have secret dinners.
We have secret meetings.
Yeah, we're gonna have fun.
-I'm ready for those parties.
-The talk show club.
Yeah, it's going to be good.
I want to say congrats
first of all
for winning another Emmy
for "Queer Eye."
-Thank you.
-Congratulations.
-You know we love you,
love the show.
But the show broke a record,
right?
I think it's been -- it won five
times in that category.
-Five times,
and it's been the most
in that category ever to happen.
And to have a show where it's
like you're doing good,
you're helping people and you're
breaking records,
it's like, come on now!
-Yeah, what more do you want?
-You know? So, I'm proud of it.
I'm proud of it.
-When you're putting the show
together,
did you talk to
any talk show hosts?
What is your inspiration
behind it?
-You were the first one.
The first thing Jimmy said to me
was, like, "Have fun."
And so like, I'm the -- you
know, like, everyone knows from
"Queer Eye," we're sort of
like a boy band.
-Yeah.
-You know what I mean?
-What is it like
when you all go out together?
-Oh, my gosh.
-Can you do that?
-Yeah, we can.
We usually go out at night
when everyone's drunk because
then nobody cares about us.
[ Laughter ]
Because drunk people are like,
"We don't give a damn
if you're on TV or not."
But when people are sober,
it's like -- I get the criers.
People come up and tell me
their emotional issues,
which I'm good with.
You know what I mean?
So come to me.
Come on the "Karamo" show.
And then Antoni gets, like,
the panties thrown
at him all the time.
-Yeah.
-Jonathan gets people wanting to
laugh with him
and, like, do their hair.
And it's like a legit boy band.
-You are a boy band.
-Yeah, we are.
-And now you break off,
you do some solo albums.
-We do some solo albums.
But listen, I'm not leaving
that check.
Okay?
-No, no, I understand.
-I'm not leaving that check.
Okay?
-No, I'm not saying that.
But let's talk about "Karamo."
It starts Monday.
-Yes.
-What can we expect
when you watch the show?
What vibe are you
going toward more?
Is it the -- Is it Oprah?
Is it Phil Donahue?
Is it Kelly Clarkson?
Drew? What are you doing?
-Karamo. I'm doing Karamo.
You know what I mean?
-Ah, of course.
That's a good --
That's the right answer.
-That's what it is.
For me, my whole life has been
about helping people
and making people be better.
Like, that's why I went into
social services.
That's what I've always done.
That's what I did on
"Queer Eye."
And so every day, people who
need help can come on my show
with their family members,
with whomever.
Y'all got conflict, come to me.
I'm going to give you advice.
I'm going to help you,
and then afterward we're going
to twerk it out a little bit.
Hey.
[ Cheers and applause ]
We'll twerk it out a little bit.
-So it's fun, but it's also --
Do you tackle serious issues?
-Yeah, we tackle
the serious issues.
It's all about, like, whatever
is going on
in your family life, your drama,
I can help you solve it.
I'm good at that.
You would imagine, like --
I have people coming to me like,
"We haven't talked in 20 years."
And by the end of my segment,
they're crying, they're kissing,
they're hugging.
-Yeah.
-And because of you, honestly,
you were like,
"Have a lot of fun,"
that like, literally,
I added dance segments.
I'm doing all this stuff
because I want to
make sure my personality
is showing.
That was your influence,
and I appreciate you for that.
-Oh, come on, bud.
You got to have fun.
-Yeah, yeah.
-People can tell
when you're having fun.
Yeah, you have to have
a good time.
We always have a good time
when you're here.
-By the way, I'm sorry.
I know you're interviewing me,
but can we talk about his beard?
[ Cheers and applause ]
This is good.
You're a supermodel, brother.
Supermodel status.
-Oh, stop it.
-Supermodel status!
-Don't even, Karamo. Come on.
-Yeah, no, it's good. It's good.
-I can't wait to watch
this show.
Monday, "Karamo," everybody.
Are there any recurring bits
on the show that you have?
-Yeah, so, one of the things
that I did because
I like to have to have proof.
I believe that's the way
you really help people,
by saying, "This is legitimately
what you need to see."
So, I'm going to be the first
show that if people come on
and they need proof,
I unlock their phones.
So, if you have a question about
your partner and you're like,
"I don't know
if they're cheating
or if something is going on,"
I will literally grab
their phone and unlock it,
and I go back up to 10 years
even if they think
they deleted it.
Trust me, trust me,
it's a good time.
-Wait, so you find --
-I'm nosy. I'm nosy.
I ain't going to lie to y'all.
Even though I like
helping people, I'm really nosy,
y'all.
-So you go through texts
and everything?
-Yeah, I have a team
and we go through everything.
And people think they're going
to be slick and they delete it
before they come out, and I'm
like, "Nope, we found it."
And literally, I do it
because people need that proof.
You know what I mean?
One of the things I hear all
the time on my show is, "I'm
staying because I love him."
Girls, if you ever say, "I'm
staying because I love him,"
that should be your first sign
to go.
I'm just letting you know.
Right now, girl, just go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
But to be able to say,
"I just tracked his locations.
Here's what he's doing
in his apps.
Here's what's going on
in his phone.
This is who he's been
talking to.
This is who he FaceTime."
Trust me, you get answers
real quick.
-Whoa!
-Yeah.
-You know what's funny?
I was actually going to say,
"what's the toughest part?"
Because I know it's
a lot of work doing a show.
You got a show, there's a lot --
you put a lot of work in.
There's a lot of time
that goes into a show.
And you're like, "Yeah, it's
tricky, but I love it.
It's all good."
And you go, "Well, you know,
one of the things was rough
was that I had to catch
these cards for a promo."
A commercial you were doing
for the show.
-I don't know who thought to put
my gay ass
in a thing
where I'm catching stuff.
I'm like, "What's going on?"
I'm helping people solving
problems, helping heal families.
Got it. Catching cards?
Boom, dead.
-We asked your production team
if you had any video of you
trying to catch these.
Here's Karamo trying to film
a promo for his show.
Watch this.
♪♪
-I got the answers.
-Where are they?
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-"Where are they?"
-Jimmy, you do it well.
-Try me.
-Are you ready?
You got it, you got it.
[ Drumroll ]
-I got it.
-Aah!
Hold on. That was my bad.
That was my bad, the throw.
-Here we go, ready?
-Keep doing the this. We got it.
-I got the answers.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Crumble like that.
Do you want to try one?
-Come on. I'm with it.
-Alright, buddy.
You got the answers?
[ Laughter ]
Alright.
You got the answers?
-I got the answers!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Come on! Good luck.
Break a leg with the show.
Karamo, everybody!
Check it out every weekday
starting this Monday.
We'll be right back with
Jann Wenner. Stick around.